so goodnight [ __ ] we're going
deep tonight oh [ __ ] is right look at
this - listen to this oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] you think that means
got a little Pat Benatar we got Lisa yet
and it's Monday night [ __ ] and you
got nothing going on nothing
[Music]
that's how we're banging out here on a
Monday night what's happening [ __ ]
uncle Joey dear oh [ __ ] we're going deep
tonight we're in training [ __ ]
that's right that's what you see is
black [ __ ] we're going deep -
let me explain something to you
in 1986 I wanted to training on cocaine
I did a grandma blow for like four
months straight understand me that's
called basic [ __ ] training that's
what we're doing right here we're not
gonna open up with one two hundred
milligrams or to two hundred milligrams
or three two hundred milligrams we're
going for for tonight that's just out
there I don't know I don't know I'm just
feeling up on Gua you know I'm saying
whatever the [ __ ] that means in French
I'm gonna take four these out for you
how you doing [ __ ] uncle Joey
here waiting I'm Marc Maron to preview
Philippe it's on Wednesday night
here you go my brother there you go four
[ __ ] stars one two
three count them with me you bad
[ __ ] you thought I was gonna
cut you short tonight you thought I'd
mean forgot three [ __ ]
[Music]
we got liquid acid we got stale brownies
we got foolish somewhere that's how
[ __ ] up I was I hit the shrooms for
myself that's like I write I hide
everything from myself because I'm a
[ __ ] Savage I thought I can't find
nothing you understand me no I'm not
that much of a fat [ __ ] I just hide you
know important alla bills bags of coke
reefer old condoms you wear a condom in
it anyway
my trusted sidekick Lisa a little what'd
you do with those other ones concepts no
no no no [ __ ] this guy's a magician
you gotta watch him he sneaks in for
later and [ __ ] it gives them my
[ __ ] with the boss and came
back with ZD is another thing I think
when I deal with 10,000 Jewish dishes
because that was [ __ ] ziti but what
are you gonna do why cry over spilt milk
they all problem they all everything
travels you understand me
I had a Cuban lady wants to put a pig on
a [ __ ] plane dead slang them out put
adobo on the [ __ ] so why here he
marinate on the flight you understand me
wrap that [ __ ] up and saran wrap
and carry them on like she own the
[ __ ] plane that's it that's how you
roll I get Cuban sandwiches in Miami I
don't get them cooked that's when I'm
right on the [ __ ] plane with nobody
says no you just make they're talking
about yes they do walking you could he
could've got [ __ ] he could have got
that [ __ ] salmon from these coasts
better he [ __ ] on me down here this
[ __ ] Salmons have gay and these coasts
that [ __ ] got dead you boiling it and
[ __ ] antibiotics that's why it's pink
it's a dead Juba that shit's good for
you he's [ __ ] people these kids these
youngsters don't understand
[Music]
we think of that concept there's 10
Indians right now jumping up and down
somewhere [ __ ] smoke signals like a
[ __ ] I hear you I'm saying if this
is Lawrence we would have been saved the
second day drink that smoke this [ __ ]
really giggling over there are you guys
doing I hope you're alright I hope your
lives are great you know and listen it's
what you [ __ ] make of it if you're
gonna sit then cry and complain you're
not getting your share you gotta go
steal it you're gonna go take it and
then they'll [ __ ] pay attention to
you and they want to back the [ __ ] that
you got the upper hand you understand me
you always got the upper hand you know
let's call balls right or wrong I'm
saying something you don't [ __ ] know
come on I'm over here smoking weed
[ __ ] having a good time you think I
give a [ __ ]
cops would come out and give a [ __ ] no
that's it it don't matter
what's up Lisa I'm a nobody like nobody
nobody comes to the Batcave here the
only the buckler [ __ ] me or begin ten
minutes remember eating [ __ ] cures
cancer if you don't know now you know I
read it again today very important like
that [ __ ] in that little especially
when that [ __ ] sweats into the
[ __ ] monkey and it's got that little
[ __ ] patois to it that's the new
immune system it girl [ __ ] pack
oh [ __ ] here at the [ __ ] voodoo
lounge for my little brother the flying
Jew and that's it what else you wanna do
with your life what did you do
what you do tell a coccyx I don't know
me neither
I went through Jitsu I got my ass kicked
I had a meeting I coordinated beaten for
an hour what a waste of my [ __ ] time
and I met with my little goombazz to
write a little bit that's it I had the
baby this morning you know meat dog I'm
a man of many [ __ ] faces many hats I
[Music]
got any a baton for now you've got a
meeting Leonie being for now I thank God
he was buying lunch if not you know I
would have to get up in the middle of
lunch and say you're a [ __ ] prophet
anyway you know me guys I keep the come
see come son ain't got time to be
[ __ ] around I'm too old
if only your uncle Joey is too old when
do you get too old I don't [ __ ] know
one day you go you know what I'm old I'm
gonna do this [ __ ] no more I just want
to smoke dope and do a [ __ ] podcast
and my little brother Lisa sitting there
like the Emperor a Saigon look him with
his little [ __ ] Catalina Island share
that who gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
you got to do what you do [ __ ] these
[ __ ] and what are you thinking over
there yo did eyeballing me like I did
something
oh I want to be matin buried in the Jew
cemetery
that's gonna be my flame too [ __ ]
that's gonna be my faint to claim my
claim to fame
I got burning the Jew cemetery next to
the baddest [ __ ] Jews in the world
understand me why I got no tattoos and
it's a Jewish state of mind right or
wrong it's a Jewish state of mind you
[ __ ] see something you think like a
white pearl huh huh huh huh
a Jew sees a tree falling he gets under
it you understand me he sues the park in
the hole for his system
you're scared of a [ __ ] tree that you
don't let the tree hit him it scratches
and he gives attention to any good joke
Juno's it's twenty to fifty a stitch you
understand me so if you get to three
stitches there's sixty [ __ ] grand a
lot of people don't know that I'm here
to tell you no you can eat stitches you
shoot somebody
those [ __ ] go up and [ __ ] violence
how you get your duties you get two
thousand stitches in your head you know
how much one is in jus dollars I can
take that to Israel live like a king
keep that [ __ ] Jew fish to forget
about it bang Israeli chick throw rocks
I could do another [ __ ] I want
it's just like me
it's just like you and that's well
that's my goal that's success anybody
can [ __ ] have a BMW go to his room
throw rocks no astronaut helmet on is
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] success okay okay
me and my wife just bought a house down
the shore was so successful sucking my
dick any [ __ ] Gentile could do that
let me see you [ __ ] get a house of
Israel and [ __ ] put the cross in your
front yard
suck my dick I've arrived I'm like king
of the Catholics got accepted what why
move to Israel put a cross in the front
yeah I'll put the same lászló statute to
ET he knows people we know Jews and
that's it people you owe me to tell you
man what else you [ __ ] wanna hear I
don't know what the [ __ ] to tell you
people you lay your lives you sitting in
your room smoke a dope and your [ __ ]
living room scratching your boy you
scratch your balls and slip your fingers
does it take you to a different place if
I tested positive for scratching my
balls - sniffing my fingers forget about
it the levels would be tremendous why
the [ __ ] did God give you fingers anyway
right or wrong leave
imitates them I'm so stoned right now
they know I'm talking about I'm just
talking to you people just to keep your
[ __ ] amuse because I love you
[ __ ] I'm with you you're with me
and they're with us okay what Jerry's
kids
let's do bong hits for [ __ ] Jerry's
kids l know L know I said it you're
gonna come to my [ __ ] party you'll
come with my body that's a good we
players and [ __ ] tremendous weed from
Sunset arable those Russians don't [ __ ]
around though these Russians got this
week the situation twisted the Russians
in Armenia thank God for a meeting it's
an ASA if you don't have a Jew in
Armenia as a friend your life ain't
worth [ __ ] you always gonna have a good
Jew as a friend in an Armenian priceless
don't like your car on fire they'll get
you new ties listen one if your friends
are Armenian you always get 20% off you
understand and if you're friends with a
Jew you get twenty so the 20 from the
r-mo the 20 from the jewel a you are
walking around 40% off [ __ ] Macy's in
the [ __ ] of what did you like women
[ __ ] them something go [ __ ] themselves I
got it
together I got a jeweler Mimi I can't
lose I set the [ __ ] Jew on you first
Armenian calls you because our meaning
is don't close you they're the only race
they get a [ __ ] Lexus zero down 200 a
month all across the country go by
Alexis you can't and next time you go by
one's used on Armenian [ __ ] knows
listen if you're not gonna smoke don't
Benitez why you have to it'll to waste
my [ __ ] time in your own time go hang
out on Catholic Dharma Christian's calm
you get together and pray and talk about
Joel Osteen and the other mind [ __ ] you
got going on this beautiful Joey show
[ __ ] we're gonna get this Jimmy
Fallon when you get this type of action
huh nowhere
don't [ __ ] don't let me find those
mushrooms we throw those things away yes
he did like I never [ __ ] number
one see he stopped these mushrooms at
steaks he don't trust the chef get that
[ __ ] psilocybin on them and get in
that juice and [ __ ] mix it with the
[ __ ] steak juice over some mashed
potatoes I have you [ __ ] I'll have
you seen things for four [ __ ] days
you understand why cuz that's how I roll
when I do mushrooms I want to see things
I'm not one of these guys let me do it
Kennedy empties I get the [ __ ] out here
I'll give you some liquid acid you'll
see B and P ten hours in a row by the
time you come down you willing to know
what [ __ ] hit you what day it is what
is it Joey who's they Thursday would you
like the Italian chicken a godfather got
blown up a bolonia Monday Sunday
Thursday
the nipple is [ __ ] me over a little
solo right here
[Music]
are you kidding me it's like a slow fire
up es ready
[Music]
Oh
now
No
are you kidding me or what this is
heroin right there right there just get
the needle
your grandmother sitting next to you
grandma hold my own pocket what happened
grandma I have no idea he told me I had
the flu shot we talked on the telephone
on distance to New York alone what the
gardener and the maize you call me on
the telephone you say Eustace all along
too tired to get dressed and get kooky
spooky in the house Timmy Holloway in
the house [ __ ] Lea and over there
giving predictions and [ __ ]
walking layers in the [ __ ] house that
bad mother [ __ ] out in Vegas running
things that [ __ ] running things and
things you got a problem vague as you
call me I quote [ __ ] let done they
find him in a [ __ ] hole up in a
canyon with an ace of spades and his
forehead you understanding why waste
precious time alright you're thinking of
[ __ ] eatin her ass don't either
what if she goes to the kitchen has a
heart attack you got to take it to the
hospital and you need me don't please s
I'm sayin I gotta sit at the funeral
ticket I should either ass
life is too short [ __ ] so why
waste precious time what time is you get
done 7:35 tick tock William Italian I
don't know what to tell you the more we
already smoked eight bowls we listen to
a hole out in the Sun and that's it
we're just getting ready for the podcast
to get started I love you guys tuning
it's my brother Marc Maron YouTube right
Matt flavors world whatever the [ __ ] it
is youtube.com slash scene where Joey
Diaz Joey Diaz all right now just tweet
it out I love you guys too I love the
hearts
I see purple hearts I see yellow and
blue and I don't give a [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] see you with 15 minutes get
your [ __ ] together look at this and we
take a shit-jerk walk because when we
start we start [ __ ] I got one
for these mushrooms anyway I'll see you
guys a little while